so
knowing all of this can now allow you to
find the target genes
how by basically doing perturbation
experiments
or by looking at the folding of the
epigenome or by looking at the genetic
impact of that genetic variant on the
expression of genes
and we use all three so let me go
through them
basically one of them is physical links
this is the folding of the genome onto
itself
how do you even figure out the folding
it's a little bit of a tangent but it's
a super awesome technology
think of the genome as again this
massive packaging that we talked about
of taking two meters worth of dna
and putting it in something that's a
million times
smaller than two meters worth of dna
that's a single cell
you basically have this massive
packaging and this packaging basically
leads to
the chromosome being wrapped around in
sort of
tight ways in ways however that are
functionally
capable of being reopened and reclosed
so i can then go in and figure out that
folding
by sort of chopping up the spaghetti
soup
putting glue and ligating the segments
that were chopped up but nearby each
other
and then sequencing through these
ligation events to figure out
that this region of these chromosomes
that region of the chromosome were near
each other
that means they were interacting even
though they were far away on the genome
itself
so that chopping up sequencing and
re-gluing
is basically giving you folds
of the genome that we said sorry can you
backtrack
how does cutting it help you figure out
which ones were close in the original
folding so you have a bowl of noodles
go on and in that bowl of noodles some
some noodles are near each other yes
so throw in a bunch of glue you
basically
freeze the noodles in place throw in a
cutter that chops up the noodles into
little pieces
now throw in some ligation enzyme that
lets those pieces that were free
re-ligating
each other in some cases they re-ligate
what you had just got
but that's very rare most of the time
they will re-ligate
in whatever was proximal
you now have glued the red noodle that
was crossing the
blue noodle to each other you then
reverse the glue the glue goes away and
you just sequence the heck out of it
most of the time you'll find red segment
with
you know red segment but you can
specifically select for ligation events
that have happened
that were not from the same segment by
sort of marking a particular way
and then selecting those and then your
sequencing you look for
red with blue matches of sort of things
that were glued
that were not immediate proximal to each
other
and that reveals the linking of the blue
noodle and the red noodle
you're with me so far yeah good so we
you know we've done these experiments
physical
that's physical step one of the physical
and what what the physical revealed is
topologically associated domains
basically big blocks of the genome
that are topologically don't you know
connected together
that's the physical the second one is
the
genetic links it basically says
across individuals that have different
genetic
variants how are their genes expressed
differently
remember before i was saying that the
path between genetics and disease is
enormous
but we can break it up to look at the
path between genetics and
gene expression so instead of using
alzheimer's as a phenotype
i can now use expression of irx3 as the
phenotype
expression of gene a and i can look at
all of the g
all of the humans who contain a g at
that location and all the humans will
contain a t
at that location and basically say wow
turns out that the expression of these
genes is higher
for the t humans than for the g humans
at that location
so that basically gives me a genetic
link between a genetic variant
a locus or region and the expression of
nearby genes good on the genetic link
i think so awesome so the third link is
the activity link what's an activity
link
it basically says if i look across 833
different epigenomes
whenever these enhancer is active
this gene is active that gives me an
activity link
between this region of the dna and that
gene
and then the fourth one is perturbations
where i can go in and
you know blow up that region and see
what are the genes that change in
expression
or i can go in and over activate that
region and see what genes
change in expression uh so i guess
that's
similar to activity yeah yeah so that's
basically similar to activity i agree
but it's causal rather than
correlational
you